oh dude you gotta check out last man on
earth oh yeah what's that about it's
good good actors funny right a beautiful
cinematography I just need like one
specific detail she's the last man on
earth
hey have you had a chance to watch it
mr. robot yet oh you know what no I
haven't be a fun thing to talk about
with you yeah I reserved the conference
room so we could watch mr. robot you
never showed have you had a chance to
watch mr. robot yet I haven't worked
okay are you watching stranger things oh
no I haven't started yet when you start
do not get attached to barb okay I won't
but don't tell me she does don't tell me
but you don't know how she dies I'm like
I don't want to be me no just please
stop you know what we should watch is
brain-dead
it's like lost but if lost why's crazy
ex-girlfriends oh my god you know we
should actually watch the office uh-huh
but if Scranton was heaven and the guy
from Cheers is there I don't know these
shows hey you do and then arias said
someday Walter I'm gonna take my knife
and I'm going out running a knife
[Music]
maybe delibird is a name it's called the
needle you like think he's gonna be a
bad guy and he's like not gonna help her
like he has problems he's flawed
character Walter White
do we know each other
oh no no we've never met buddy how you
doing so ramsey who is the king right
easy buddy dog you had a chance to watch
mr. robot yeah no still have it he had
to die at the end they take a good guy
and they turn him into a villain like
friends but like a couple of the friends
are all purple I need you to watch mr.
no talk about it tomorrow
search for documentaries on space cool
what is this it's good thanks
[Music]
I haven't watched it yet